[Music]
did you guys know that there is a
family in turkey that walks on all fours
like the horse girls
the horse girl sick remember the horse
girl man at first i was laughing at her
and then later on i was like it's kind
of turning me on a bit isn't she your
child
just the action of it i thought she was
raised by horses
i thought she was just practicing she
was just into horses oh i don't know
she's talented she actually moves like a
horse though all right
[Music]
oh my play man
i love this music man it's really epic
this one still wears boots what the [ __ ]
let me get this dad out of here
okay that's more normal hands and feet
[Music]
wow look at their hands oh they're like
hands go like this
only some of them most of them use their
palms oh
that makes more sense to me i want to
see their hands though i don't know if
they're faking it or not
but look at like the [ __ ] their spine
posture and [ __ ] you can tell that it's
like rounded and like look how they
can't [ __ ] fully look up
like everything has to look like this
you know what i mean
and like how their their bottom feet or
their bottom feet because they got four
feet their feet are turned out you know
what i'm saying because they can only
kind of like that holy [ __ ] this this
soundtrack is like
when you're in a
war movie
and you lose your homies and [ __ ] and
you're looking around everything's
slow-mo yeah right a bomb just went off
you can't really hear you're like there
are four young women
why is everyone coming in one at a time
how come they don't carpool or the
entrance yeah it's just it's just an
entrance yeah that's all how would that
cardboard i don't know they would sit on
their back yeah i wonder how they drive
or if they drive because they couldn't
they don't okay so tucked in a remote
corner of turkey amid dirt tracks and
stone houses live is a family that
appears to throw out four million years
of evolution originally touted by
turkish scientists to be backward
evolution several members of the ulus
family walk on all fours now their their
family is huge though they got [ __ ]
like 18 19 oh out of 19 children born to
reside and haties euless who walk
upright
five siblings walk using their feet and
their palms on their hands with
astounding agility and what researchers
first thought was a relapse there's 19
kids there's 19 kids [ __ ] a lot they
[ __ ] dude they [ __ ] like dogs or like
the friends i was wondering
well no the two the two the parents are
regular they walk up right what about
the kids like i don't know if the kids
[ __ ] to be honest how did they start
walking like that
i don't know that's why that's why
turkish scientists uh literally just
diagnosed it as uh backwards
evolutionary leaps dude 19 kids that's
crazy that's why she couldn't [ __ ]
teach him how to stand that's probably
exactly what it was he's not even
worried about them walking on a force
he's like [ __ ] 19 kids
this is crazy that mom was too busy
[ __ ] popping out babies and actually
raise them she was pregnant all the time
that's why they were crawling and they
just never got to the [ __ ] point
where they stood up but kids learn
on their own though
well these guys are like late bloomers
yeah it's called like a part of
imprinting you know like when you have
like uh
like a bunny raised by two chickens the
bunny will go like this
and they'll move with its bunny parts
but they'll go like this because it's
like they they learn from watching in
the first place i think one [ __ ] stop
never stood up and then the other
siblings just like watch the crawler and
they're like i'm gonna be like brother
crawl probably
that's probably the only way it worked
because it's like
the whole family does it no no only uh
well technically five of the 19 kids
dude there was a sixth one as well six
sibling also walked on all fours but
sadly died at age five there's a um
kid or like a person in russia who was
left in the backyard like neglected and
then um they were raised by the dogs so
they move like a dog they act like a dog
they walk on all fours which is why i'm
like a little bit more confused of this
one because they're around other humans
that walk upright and not all of their
siblings walk like that no it's just the
five yeah and because of the taunts they
receive the women tend to stay close to
the house but according to scientists
who study the family their brother
sometimes wanders for several kilometers
and has basic interactions with other
people in the village so the brother
just [ __ ]
galloping like that yeah
[Music]
so scientifically speaking if they were
to be uh reflective of our like previous
uh you know
evolutionary part of our past um usually
primal primates would be walking more so
on their knuckles or or
it was it was believed that we you know
before we evolved we're walking on our
knuckles but these uh people
specifically walk on like the palms of
their hands and stuff so that's huge
calluses on their palms so it's not
exact to the idea of just like reversing
our evolution it's just an anomaly
there's this new movement of people
walking on their hands for like 20
minutes a day or like 30 minutes you
mean like they hand stand and walk like
they'll just move around walk around and
it's supposed to help get rid of all
kinds of arthritis and all kinds of like
uh
like stuff that might you know you know
we're not supposed to be sitting so a
lot of us have hip or tight hips yeah
and then so we're not supposed to be
like on our phones with just our thumbs
or stuff like that and like this is
supposed to help activate i don't know
release all kinds of tension that we
have built i mean exercise is different
from lifestyle though right you know
what i mean like this is that's to the
extreme it's like what these guys are
doing but all day yeah
damn
they look kind of funny though dude like
when a human being isn't like moving
like like what we're used to seeing and
then it's like a full grown adult with
their butt in the air it's like
man
are you are you still human i don't know
just i get confused i'm like it's like a
dog it can't be that efficient
but it's like a human it doesn't seem
like it's that efficient no it looks
like they stop to like fairly carefully
pay attention mainly because of like the
placement of like your eye and stuff
yeah and then they couldn't like lift
their heads that's what you said right
there's gotta be so much weight going
forward right because your legs are your
legs are usually longer than your front
versus like having like pretty even limb
space and also like
you know actual real estate for like
usage of your your your hands but how
often do they get kicked by people
because people not not because they're
[ __ ] but because they can't see them
so they walk around they go oh [ __ ] my
bad it's an issue for the brother not
the sisters because they tend to stay at
home
the brother's the one kind of like out
and about [ __ ] roaming around yeah
none of the five who are now aged
roughly between 25 and 41 years old
attended school but were able to learn
enough kurdish to communicate with their
own family there's this part of the
article i read where they had dogs
walking on two feet walking some of
these people too
damn do they have a leash for the people
that's opposite land turkish
and then the dog wasn't looking like
this anymore it's looking like this and
he was like like they had them on a
leash
like i wonder what their spines look
like or if they've done any x-rays
because i feel like
most i i think humans are probably not
supposed to be walking like that all the
time and i feel like that's gotta have
some sort of like you know effect on you
could see in their back like their mid
back is like super rounded hella curve
that can't be good over time so here's a
little little anecdote um
so some scientists had said that it was
like devolution right the evolution but
one other professor said
that they believe it is instead down to
genetic and developmental circumstances
the affected siblings whose parents are
second cousins all suffer from a
congenital brain impairment cerebral
cerebellar i was gonna just say was
there some inbreeding going on there
yeah so meaning they find balancing on
two legs difficult and so their motor
development was channeled into turning
their crawl into a type of bipedalism so
it's a cause of function not because
it's like cause they get dizzy and [ __ ]
just standing and they're like whoa i
need a [ __ ] more support here in the
video some of the girls you can see
their feet they're like
their their ankles are inward
so like i didn't know if that was
because of them crawling all the time
but it's probably because of their power
like that dr schulz
that's what they need they need some
orthotics dude they're raising the
arches that's true
yeah yeah they need some [ __ ]
sketchers
you know this is why you shouldn't [ __ ]
your cousins
yeah this is a psa
no matter how fine they are yep
do you guys have any fine cousins
they had 19 kids so the probabilities of
some of them having some type of genetic
issues is liked awful this makes sense
it's like duffel
quite true they're also from a very
small town in turkey so maybe there
aren't many options for them yeah and
realistically too when you you know
if your cousin's like super fine it's
like you ain't gonna have problems just
just your children's children will
that's true yeah you might not even be
alive i mean the royalties did it yeah
but that's why they all bald very early
oh yeah but they didn't know that the
next guy balded earlier they was just
like they just boggling i feel like
there's a lineage of all the men in
their family
one of my buddies that goes to iceland a
lot he says in iceland there's an app
um because it's pretty much like a
homogeneous society where like you can
put the app in and then people put in
their information and they'll see how
far apart they are because people are
not trying to date their cousins but
it's so hard like everyone is
technically like a fourth or fifth
cousin
so like the minute they have any like
new foreigner blood or whatever comes in
everyone's like oh where's this from
iceland yeah so for all you guys out
there that are single and ready to
mingle and can't find anybody out here
go to iceland
yeah they're gonna be they're gonna be
coming for you yeah
i like scandinavian cultures
because they [ __ ] first date later
really do they really do you have any
experiences
true likings
is there a story you want to share about
that
i watched the documentary i watched a
documentary
[ __ ] first date later it's true that i
watch the show vikings that stands the
test of time oh
that's a good thing is it even a date
later is it just murder afterwards it
could be either one okay
very romantic it's a lot of pillaging in
that series huh depending on how the sex
went you know then they'll decide
afterwards
[Music]
foreign